pleasure to talk with you this morning
thank you you - I wonder what from here
in I am in my bedroom are you
it's cozy right we can get out of covers
if we don't like how it's going there we
go it's a pajama party well it's really
fun to talk with you but it seems like
getting the getting the band back
together for the special was a was a
real joy was that your first
what did she we had such fun and yeah I
was doing a dramatic series at that time
and got to jump out and do this
hilarious thing by Tina Fey and Robert
Carlock level these great actors and
Daniel wag cool oh my god be sexy with
so I hope there's another one but yeah
so it just was really great we had our
same DP John in word I had my makeup
artist a cappella green on my
hairdresser key and of course my
fabulous cast and I was not present when
Titus ate the dirt but I enjoyed being
able to watch it so what was your
reaction when they told you that they
wanted to do this as an interactive
special I had no idea what they were
talking about and I feared that when it
came out I would not be able to figure
out how to do it but as it turns out
even I a complete computer illiterate
was able to do it very easily they make
it very easy for you and now you have to
watch it 400 times so because every end
of every scene for each character you
get to pick a different direction that
they go in and every time you pick a
different direction you're watching like
a completely different movie oh did I
say the handsome Jon Hamm is in the
movie did I say but I didn't get a
chance with him at that early temper she
did yeah there's that
scenes together are great I did jump a I
do want to loop back because you didn't
mention Daniel Radcliffe you got to do a
lot of fun stuff with him I get to sing
a sexy song to him I got to kiss his
beautiful mouth which am I
saying things that are gonna shock
people cuz I'm like four times as old as
him probably right and oh yeah I just
got to have so much fun with them and
he's just such a kind guy and a
hilarious guy it seems like watching it
it was almost like it was almost
shocking that he hasn't been a part of
the cast this whole time he seemed to
really fit in doesn't he he just fits
him so naturally and he you know he I
guess it's just like I'd say he's very
kind and empathetic came Valerius like
funny and so we figured like what why
wouldn't he been there the whole time of
course when you were actually filming
you know was it complicated to basically
keep track of you know what was you know
what what what different branches you
were on in terms of there a little bit
but we were reminded by wonderful
director Claire Scanlon and Tina and
Robert and Jeffery Richmond our composer
wrote the lovely little song I get to
sing as Daniels British nanny so they
were always trying to keep us apprised
of where we were in the story would they
have like a chart that they would show
you no no they they they had it in their
been away Jenna script I have to say it
was written down first I mean I can
imagine those are it's a much more
complicated script than you usually got
oh my god this thing you had to hire
somebody just to walk around with the
script it was so big I mean it was like
I guess I'm dating myself again by
saying it was like when we had telephone
books but you know it was like a thing
like this yeah I mean in terms of you
know of all the things you got to do
I've played through it three times now
and I still feel like
there I think there's I still feel like
there are things I'm missing cues or is
there one thing in particular that you
hope people discover when they play and
there's one thing in particular because
there's so much that's so delicious
and well you know it's interesting that
titus and Ellie have a sort of a Roady
picture they have their own Road movie
going on you know for those of you who
remember Road movies and I love James
whole story and in Titus's trailer where
she pretends forever that Titus is in
there being a diva and has to admit at
the end that he's not even there and I
love that story and yeah I mean there's
so many great things and as I say my
little provocative work with Daniel did
you know in advance when you read it did
you know in advance that he would be
that he was starring yeah they told us
that's wonderful but I didn't know what
he'd be like and then he'd be so easy
and that I would never feel like I had
to change in any way to be working with
them I mean you mentioned that you got
to play a dual role and as his nanny was
that was it was it was it easy to slip
into the British accent yes there was a
change I have to say I've always wanted
to play something like that and wear
that little suit that Tina Nigro made
for me and that was silly had my little
Mary Poppins had it was just really fun
wonderful well I mean how are you
keeping busy right now what's uh what's
oh okay I'm keeping busy with my boy
special and I NT be busy seeing my mama
lives in the same building who's a
musician and should play a piano joy
Kane and I'm keeping busy trying
desperately to clean my floors and when
I say trying desperately I should add
that I'm not succeeding
well we are all doing the best we can
right now I bring a generosity
well I need an either wrap things up but
I do want to ask do you you know just
you know and you mentioned you were
working on traumatic so I'm assuming
that was hunters do you have any any any
thoughts news about us a potential
season - well no I mean I know they've
written it but we as we don't know it's
going to be in our future as you know
none of us know when the world opens up
if it's done in the right way that
doesn't kill a lot more people we don't
know exactly when we'll all go back to
work but I hope it'll be - and I hope
everyone stays safe from take care yeah
absolutely
well thank you so much spin as have been
as such a pleasure talking with you
today and I hope the rest of these are
equally fun they will be I guarantee it